[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález todo comenzó el
28 de abril con una serie de
manifestaciones en diferentes ciudades
colombianas para pedir el retiro de una
controvertida reforma fiscal dichas
manifestaciones se tornaron violentas y
dieron paso a hechos de vandalismo que
afectaron la infraestructura de ciudades
como bogotá cali pereira entre otras
pero también dejaron heridos y muertos
tanto del lado de los manifestantes como
de las fuerzas armadas nadie en ese
momento contemplaba la posibilidad de
que estas manifestaciones y jornadas de
paro nacional diera origen a un gran
estallido social encabezado por los
jóvenes y estudiantes que hacen eco de
reclamos que vienen de muchos años atrás
y que el estado colombiano no ha sabido
solucionar el panorama en el siguiente
informe veamos
los reclamos al gobierno colombiano no
cesan cuando está a punto de cumplirse
un mes de protestas los manifestantes
rechazan que no se haya dado aún
respuesta a sus peticiones y tiran la
pelota al campo del ejecutivo para
terminar la crisis depende
fundamentalmente de que el gobierno
atienda esas peticiones y de alguna
manera la gente evalúe si se resuelven
los problemas sociales que tienen que
ver con el hambre con la pobreza con la
exclusión por ejemplo si tenemos una
renta básica otras exigencias son el
acceso universal a la educación superior
el desarme del escuadrón antidisturbios
y una reforma policial ante las
constantes denuncias de abusos de la
fuerza pública en las protestas la ong
local temblores resalta 60 asesinatos en
las manifestaciones 43 atribuidos a la
fuerza pública pero aún en esta
situación el gobierno es renuente a la
entrada de veedores internacionales
solicitamos al gobierno colombiano que
permita la entrada de la comisión
interamericana de derechos
para que ellos en el terreno se den
cuenta que es lo que ha ocurrido en
nuestro país en cuanto a violación de
derechos humanos en contra de
declaraciones previas y tras la presión
la vicepresidenta a marta lucía ramírez
abrió la puerta a una entrada anticipada
de la comisión
en una ruptura con el gobierno nacional
la alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez
entregó un informe a la representante de
la alta comisionada de naciones unidas
para los derechos humanos sobre la
violencia ocurrida en la capital que
incluye la investigación de la muerte de
dos jóvenes por otro lado la corte
suprema del país hizo un llamado al cese
inmediato de la violencia después de que
una turba e incendiara el palacio de
justicia del municipio de tuluá cercano
a la ciudad de cali epicentro de las
protestas las altas cortes no han
rechazado el uso desmedido de la fuerza
policial
así las cosas colombia lleva ya un mes
de bloqueos jornadas de paro violencia
en las calles desabastecimiento y una
economía que se está viniendo abajo y en
un pico de pandemia que se percibe como
interminable con máximos de contagio
diario superiores a los 20 mil casos
para un total de 3.2 millones de casos
de kobe 19 todo esto ante una mesa de
diálogo que avanza lento muy lento para
buscar una solución un mes de estallido
social en colombia nuestro tema de
debate aquí en france 24 y para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a maría del
rosario guerra ella senadora del partido
centro democrático que es el partido
oficialista al que también pertenece el
presidente de colombia iván duque ella
se encuentra en la ciudad de bogotá a la
capital colombiana y también se une a
esta conversación
adam isacson él es director de la
veeduría de defensa de la oficina en
washington para asuntos latinoamericanos
y él se une a esta conversación por
supuesto de la ciudad de washington la
capital de eeuu les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar sus preguntas y comentarios
en las en redes sociales
el canal se le recuerda estamos en
facebook también no se encuentran en
instagram y en twitter como france24
santi logo y la etiqueta es numeral el
debate entre 24 dejen todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas comienzo
entonces con la senadora maría del
rosario guerra en la ciudad de bogotá
preguntándole un mes ya de estallido
social en colombia ya dábamos a conocer
cómo está el panorama del país porque no
hay soluciones
buenas noches un saludo para ustedes y
para las personas que nos siguen mis
gracias por la invitación
aquí hay claramente una estrategia de
desestabilización de agitación social de
permear esta expresión ciudadana por el
narcotráfico por grupos al margen de la
ley como la disidencia de las farc de
células de ln y otras bandas criminales
lamentablemente esa expresión de un
grupo de ciudadanos que después de una
pandemia se han visto afectados en sus
ingresos en sus negocios en sus
actividades termino degenerando en
violencia una violencia que como bien
dice ustedes lleva un mes pero de mes y
vi que el pretexto fue el proyecto de
reforma fiscal denominado eso de
solidaria sostenible pero esta marcha
estaba prevista
un par de meses antes siquiera de que el
gobierno la revista derretida por parte
del congreso y aún continúa hoy por
ejemplo el fueron agredidos ocho
miembros de la fuerza pública y
efectivamente los que más han estado
sufriendo son la policía más de 1.165
policías agredidos durante este proceso
de manifestación entonces realmente no
encontramos primero una pues una
cuestión en los niveles de esta paro de
estas manifestaciones porque muchos de
este vandalismo se ha dado por otros
grupos que no tienen que ver con este
comité que inició las marchas pero ha
degenerado en una violencia contra
bienes públicos contra las instituciones
colombianas contra la policía contra la
infraestructura de justicia y tenemos
que rechazar las cosas muy importantes
que quede claro que el gobierno ha
mostrado toda la disposición para
luchar y avanzar siempre y cuando cese
la violencia sí señor y saxon en la
ciudad de washington la perspectiva
internacional porque desde su opinión no
hay un acuerdo en colombia para poner
fin a este estallido social que ya
cumple un mes
puedes lograr un acuerdo sobre temas tan
profundos es bastante difícil del pueblo
colombiano está angustiado la después de
14 meses y medio de pandemia hay 7
millones de colombianos en la pobreza
quienes no estaban en la pobreza hacia
principios de 2020 hay mucho más en la
clase media que están con temor de caer
en la pobreza hay por lo menos 4
millones de jóvenes entre las edades de
15 y 30 que están estudiando ni
trabajando y muchos quieren estudiar y
trabajar con tanta angustia y yo no
comparto la idea de que hay una
conspiración internacional nacional
grupos armados con capacidad de
movilizar tanta gente
creo que las protestas que estamos
viendo son mucho más orgánicos y vienen
con reclamos más profundos que realmente
no pueden negociar en una pequeña mesa
en bogotá entre algunos ministros y
algunos jefes de sindicatos creo que la
mayoría de los que están protestando
que el gobierno de iván de que en los 14
meses que le quedan 15 meses que quieran
en el poder no va a poder entregar mucho
creo que la mayoría solamente quieren
ser escuchados y tomados en cuenta y una
manera de escucharlos y tomarlos en
cuenta es no simplemente registrarlos
como una cátedra de violentos
manipulados por grupos armados y
narcotraficantes no creo que eso es
cierto
en las protestas después del asesinato
de georges fluir aquí en eeuu hace un
año si había una franja también violenta
estaba rompiendo ventanas y quemando
carlos y cosas así pero 99 punto algo
por ciento de los que participaban en
nuestras protestas lo hicieron de manera
pacífica y de una manera muy
disciplinada senado la guerra porque al
gobierno colombiano le ha costado le ha
costado tanto entender la situación
engranar en sus acciones para ponerle
fin a esta ola de violencia que se ha
vivido a lo
estas semanas en ese país suramericano y
le ha costado y así lo demuestran varios
medios internacionales entender la
situación articularse y sobre todo
aproximarse a esos ciudadanos que están
manifestando y se ha escudado en que
todos son delincuentes narcotraficantes
o que son infiltrados o que son ex
integrantes de la guerrilla de las farc
o que son parte de la actual guerrilla
de la ln y no ha hecho una aproximación
exitosa
primero el gobierno nacional del
presidente iván duque ha sido respetuoso
de los ciudadanos que han expresado en
las calles la insatisfacción por las
diferentes situaciones que están
viviendo segundo el gobierno no sólo hoy
sino en el 2019 que también unas marchas
grandes ha escuchado y ha acogido alguna
de las propuestas pero es muy difícil
cuando quieren imponer un plan de
gobierno que no fue el plan de gobierno
con el cual te hizo elegir iván duque
márquez a la presidencia entonces no
sólo tienen 18 puntos el comité del paro
sino que cada vez cuando ve que se
avanza en un punto introduce en otro
esto hay que tomarlo seriamente este es
un gobierno que en materia de educación
superior no sólo está comprometido con
la gratuidad para los estratos más
vulnerables de la población sino también
que como consecuencia de un paro
anterior por
esta lección el presupuesto para las
universidades públicas segundo muy
importante frente a la angustia que
viven los ciudadanos por la pandemia y
la pérdida de ingreso unos programas
sociales de transferencia monetaria que
le llega a casi 9 millones de hogares en
colombia que eso son cerca unos 27
millones de personas tercero hay unas
solicitudes que han hecho en el paro
inaceptable como vamos a eliminar al
smac que es el grupo de la constitución
y la ley creo para frenar los disturbios
para recuperar el orden para evitar el
caos es que hay que pensar en todos los
ciudadanos no sólo los ciudadanos que
protestan sino también aquellos que no
lo hacen y por eso tenemos que frenar
que se permea de los violentos está en
marcha mire dos ejemplos cali y armenia
esta semana hicieron unas marchas del
silencio multitudinarias tiene una sola
acto de violencia si es posible y
colombia
y yo he participado también en martes
entonces lo que estamos rechazando que
se permea por estos grupos violentos que
terminan degenerando la la expresión
pacífica legítima de los ciudadanos de
expresar su inconformismo señor isaacson
de acuerdo a las palabras de la senadora
guerra da la sensación que entonces se
están confundiendo acá unos pedidos que
son válidos por parte de la ciudadanía
en unas manifestaciones pacíficas con
unas exigencias que pueden ser según
retomando un poco lo que es el hace nada
innecesarias por ejemplo lo de la
eliminación del esmad que también ha
estado en el ojo de las críticas por el
abuso policial y por haber causado
heridas a numerosos ciudadanos en las
manifestaciones cuando se han producido
choques está entonces el comité del paro
tal vez pidiendo más allá excediendo sus
límites generando inestabilidad con un
fin bajo de cuerda como lo vio usted
pues no veo al comité del paro
con lucha con mucho liderazgo sobre esto
claro que ellos tienen algunas
solicitudes que no se pueden otorgar no
se pueden satisfacer en cuestión de
entre hora y agosto 2022 está impidiendo
así algunos cambios muy más sistémicos a
que el gobierno de edu que ni siquiera
va a poder pagar mucho menos estar
dispuesto de cumplir también el tema de
que el cometido paro aunque son de muy
comprometida con el cambio social
son no representan a todos los que están
en la calle y son muy unos viejos y
varones
líderes sindicales y unos pequeños
grupos que representan otros sectores
del sindicalismo juega un papel
importante pero los jóvenes que están en
las calles los indígenas la gente afro
los grupos de mujeres de elgeta
no realmente no son los que están
sentados en esas mesas con el ministerio
entonces
el proceso del diálogo necesario es más
amplio pero probablemente el diálogo es
90% de lo que hay que hacer hay que ver
más ver cambio y si las instituciones
estaban funcionando bien esos esos
reclamos se pudieran procesar a través
del congreso por los líderes elegidos
pero 20 no se siente y especialmente en
el dolor que están no se sienten
representados sobre el tema de las más
rápidamente ese es un cuerpo de policial
del estudios que se creó en el año 1999
que lleva armas supuestamente no de
letales a pesar de eso el smart es
responsable responsable de
aproximadamente dos terceras partes de
los muertos y desde el 28 de abril algo
va mal con el smart no solamente con la
manera en que actúan
pero también su estrategia es muy
posible que con una ética más basada en
el escalamiento
a situaciones difíciles con muchos
hombres los las protestas no se hubieran
prolongado tanto a la misma reacción de
la policía muchas veces se convierte en
una razón para que la gente siguen
saliendo a las calles y ss por eso hay
que repensar todo lo que representa y
cómo actúa el smart señor y saxon
continuo con usted ya le doy la palabra
senador aguirre quiero preguntarle señor
isaksson allí en la ciudad de washington
sobre la percepción que hay a nivel
internacional del estado colombiano a lo
largo de este mes se está mostrando un
estado debilitado asimismo lo ha dicho
la corte suprema colombiana al mencionar
hechos como lo ocurrido en tuluá que
veíamos las imágenes del palacio de
justicia en llamas después de una
jornada de manifestaciones que
terminaron en choques con las con la
policía local
esto está erosionando las bases del
estado colombiano que ya de hecho trae
muchos problemas de mucha debilidad por
lo menos en cuanto a la presencia de
estado en algunos rincones del país
siendo así
pues aquí en móvil hablar para
washington aquí ver un estallido social
en cualquier país de la del mundo
después de 14 meses de pandemia nos
sorprende porque sabemos que el dolor y
tuvimos cierto tipo de estudio social
aquí hace un año y también alrededor del
6 de enero son cosas que pasan cuando a
la caída libre económica
agravan mucho las tensiones sociales
pero dicho eso si hay cierta confusión
aquí en colombia
hemos llevado la idea de que desde plan
colombia las fuerzas de seguridad
colombianos no cometieran a tantos
abusos de derechos humanos pero nos
siguen llegando vídeos y testimonios en
nuestros periódicos principales de los
víctimas de que la actuación de la
policía es bastante abusiva y aquí
estamos en eeuu tratando de procesar ese
tema de abuso policía porque hemos
tenido bastantes vídeos aquí desde
fabricantes y es un tema que si suena
mucho venden las mentes de muchos aquí
en eeuu lo que no se entiende aquí en
esto no sé si hay episodios de violencia
en las márgenes pero no sabemos por qué
siguen tantos en el país como lo que
pasó en uno hace dos noches pero también
no entendemos ese fenómeno de los
bloqueos entre carreteras en carreteras
entre ciudades que logran ser arturo un
país por un mes entero las cargas los
bloqueos dentro de una ciudad de los
jóvenes que
no bloqueen muchos comercios y eso es
algo que uno puede imaginar provocar una
carretera por un mes entero y sin
reacción es algo un poco difícil de
explicar aquí precisamente está la
pregunta que le quería hacer a la
senadora guerra si estás estos bloqueos
en las carreteras del país una nación
que necesita de la red vial para poder
comunicarse y para poder movilizar
productos entre las diferentes regiones
debido a su complicada geografía no
demuestra precisamente una debilidad del
estado en dar respuesta a esta situación
tener una ciudad sin abastecimiento de
combustible sin permitirle la entrada de
los alimentos e incluso el paso de las
ambulancias no demuestra una clara
debilidad estatal
mire yo antes de responder eso debe
precisar en los últimos tres o cuatro
años precisamente desde que hubo el a
los diálogos para el acuerdo de paz
entre el gobierno de juan manuel fa
santo y la farc han querido estigmatizar
a la policía colombiana y acabar el smac
déjeme decirle que no es cierto que las
principales violencia que se hayan dado
en este mes por el esmad por el
contrario nos duele a los colombianos
que de bien que mil 165 policías hoy
hayan sido irrespetados y hayan sido
victimizados a más incluso que en los
civiles 622 calles que son los puestos
de policía hay sido quemados o
vandalizado en el solo día de hoy cuatro
de ocho policías que iban de civil que
eran administrativos fueron secuestrados
por una sola y más tratado ha habido
policías quemados con ácido y quemados
con fuego esto para decirles que también
ha habido mucha información falsa
montaje en las redes sociales hay casos
ya de violaciones de algunos miembros de
la policía que se están investigando
para ya ocho casos que se están
documentando aquí se dijo por parte de
una persona que lo había violado un
policía y esta semana reconoció que
había inventado que era mentira no es
también mi invitación a la prensa
internacional es que
y ven muy bien la información que está
saliendo porque hay mucha información
que es mentira que es monta y que es
para afectar a la policía ya la fuerza
pública porque siempre han querido como
son las que luchan contra la violencia
contra el narcotráfico contra la
criminalidad han querido siempre
afectarlo y atacarlo y con relación al
tema por supuesto por supuesto que los
bloqueos hay que condenarlo y rechazarlo
y están hoy afectando tanto la
estructura económica que se estima que
cuestan 1 casi 12 1.2 por ciento del
producto interno bruto se ha perdido en
este mes cómo se ha retrocedido de
manera importante el estado de ánimo en
la población y se ha perdido de manera
importante en bienestar social entonces
esto esto ha golpeado duramente a
colombia ya sus instituciones y la
estrategia es desinstitucionalizar por
eso no todos las personas los gremios de
la producción ciudadanos
hemos comenzado una campaña de expresión
para decir no más bloqueos no más
afectación a los bienes públicos no más
atentado en la fuerza pública y que se
sigan expresando pacíficamente las
expresiones ciudadanas de inconformidad
está bien pero no los violentos que
están permeando hoy tristemente en las
calles colombianas mi senadora
complementó esas cifras que usted nos da
con información que ha registrado la ong
temblores que dice que desde el 28 de
abril o sea hace un mes exactamente
cuando empezaron estas protestas ha
habido 3.155 hechos de violencia por
parte de la policía y los ciudadanos en
los enfrentamientos que ha habido y
precisamente eso me lleva al siguiente
tema senadora y es el tema de los
desaparecidos que le preocupa muchísimo
a la comunidad internacional aquí
se han encendido las alarmas a nivel
internacional porque no hay congruencia
en las cifras por ejemplo la fiscalía
dice que son 129 las personas
desaparecidas pero la ong indepaz dice
que son 346 la canciller ramírez en su
encuentro en la ciudad de washington
dijo que era una persona de quienes
entonces aquí la persona que tenga la de
quién es entonces la información y que
pueden decir desde el gobierno sobre
estos desaparecidos la información en la
institucional fiscalía general de la
nación y déjeme decirle a mí me da pena
pero están dos ongs o no dejen de
izquierda son ong que no tienen
información veraz que están detrás del
proceso de agitación social y
deslegitimación de la fuerza pública y
de esa persona que hablan de
desaparecido ya han documentado más de
80 casos que no son desaparecidos
entonces por eso vale la pena seguir la
información oficial de la defensoría del
pueblo y de la fiscalía general de la
nación que son los docentes
independientes que debe que están
manejando esa información y por eso no
es cierto lo que dicen estas dos ong al
final yo si les pido que no comencemos a
poner como fuentes oficiales ong que
tienen sesgos ideológicos y políticos y
quien lo el interés que tienen también
es desinformar señor y saxon su
perspectiva sobre este tema de los
desaparecidos que genera mucha
preocupación en la comunidad
internacional en los organismos como
naciones unidas o la oea han llamado la
atención porque ven que colombia pues
están ocurriendo estos casos y las
instituciones son muy lentas a la hora
de actuar precisamente a la hora de dar
las cifras a la hora de investigar los
casos y es ha sido la razón o la
explicación que ha dado la canciller en
su reunión en washington diciendo que no
habían permitido la llegada de la
comisión verificadora del cdh porque
precisamente querían investigar pero es
que llevamos un mes de estos hechos y
colombia está avanzando muy lentamente
si nosotros en bola cuando hablamos de
las cifras normalmente necesitamos lo
que viene de la fiscalidad y también a
lo que viene de temblores y de indepaz
porque porque de hecho el temblor es en
de paz pueden hacer como estar
cometiendo errores pero son mucho más
transparentes a que la fiscalía en cómo
llegan a sus cifras es un bueno una
buena buena investigación en la página
investigativa la silla vacía donde
trataba y trataban y trataban de
convencerle a la fiscalía de explicarles
cómo es que llega nuestro sus números
como sólo 17 a muertos confirmados
y no lograron una respuesta bastante
clara entonces tenemos que mencionar los
dos con la suposición de que la verdad
del número verdadero está en medio por
eso es tan importante que venga la cdh
que tiene esa credibilidad
internacional a su reputación de ser muy
imparcial y su acceso a todos los
actores
a estatales y no estatales para que
ellos nos pueden dar un poco más luz
sobre lo que está pasando señor y saxon
no es muy mal visto que un país como
colombia que tiene tantos problemas de
fondo a nivel social no permita la
entrada a su territorio de una comisión
del 6 de h para que haga una
investigación sobre lo que está
sucediendo el país prohíbe
momentáneamente como lo ha dicho el
gobierno colombiano de manera oficial
este ingreso de esta comisión porque
espera avanzar por su cuenta en las
investigaciones no queda muy mal a nivel
internacional esto no le resta
credibilidad al gobierno
es mala óptica y si le quita argumentos
del gobierno colombiano cuando dicen que
según un cuerpo como ha unido una
instancia como sede así no puede venir
pero parece que el gobierno colombiano
está agilizando tratando un poco su
posición y vamos a ver una visita desde
aceite h en el futuro no muy lejano
y senadora guerra su perspectiva sobre
este tema entendemos que el gobierno
está tratando de acelerar los casos de
investigar lo más rápido posible
estas denuncias que hay de violaciones
de derechos humanos de desaparecidos de
personas fallecidas pero la población
está exigiendo resultados más rápido
precisamente se critica esa lenta acción
por parte de la fiscalía y también de la
defensoría del pueblo para investigar
qué pueden decir yo le tengo que decir
que si bien soy muy respetuoso del
sistema interamericano tengo muchas
dudas sobre la imparcialidad de la cdh
entre otras cosas porque lo acabamos de
ver con un candidato de colombia que
aspiraba a ser miembro y por sus ojos
por su creencia religiosa lo estaban
estigmatizando y de hecho apartando y
hemos visto los pronunciamientos de la
comisión interamericana derechos humanos
donde difícilmente difícilmente se ponen
a favor del estado colombiano siempre
siempre ha sido condenas al estado
colombiano yo en lo personal mi
invitación es que es
importante el sistema interamericano
pero tristemente esta comisión algunos
de sus miento habiendo han sido
claramente sesgado claramente según su
posición y él fue el estado colombiano
no debe temer a que ellos o cualquier
otro venga pero aquí hay una
instituciones serias como la fiscalía
como la defensoría del pueblo y la misma
corte suprema- los jueces colombianos
que hagan su trabajo y que una vez ellos
tengan esa información venga a la
comisión interamericana está bien pero
lo que no podemos nosotros poner en duda
es el sistema jurídico colombiano que ha
sido un sistema jurídico centenario con
imperfecciones pero centenario serio y
que creemos que está en toda la
capacidad actual liderado con la
fiscalía general de la nación senadora
tomando en cuenta la coyuntura en la que
está el país y las críticas que ha
recibido la policía y el esmad es
momento para que este país tal vez
plantee la posibilidad de hacer una
reforma a la policía nacional
de hecho se viene trabajando en ello el
señor ministro de defensa
en este gobierno ya se han hecho unos
avances significativos en ese sentido y
nuestra policía le debe quedar claro a
todos los que nos siguen y en practicar
respetuoso de la constitución y de la
ley y siempre han sido respetuoso en los
derechos humanos por eso debe decirles
que se está trabajando en ese tema pero
no le pidan a colombia que tiene
narcotráfico que tiene grupos criminales
guerrillas no le pida a colombia que
acabe con las fuentes de la seguridad
urbana que es la policía nacional y la
que combate el narcotráfico por el
contrario lo que estamos trabajando es
para fortalecer yo y cada vez más que
ellos asuman la defensa de la mano y la
constitución es la ley de los derechos
humanos de la seguridad ciudadana y por
supuesto de la presencia en zonas
urbanas señor isaacson ha quedado en
entredicho
varias veces a lo largo de este mes en
torno a estas manifestaciones de
estudiantes y de ciudadanos el tema de
los bloqueos ya lo estábamos mencionando
acá esto desvirtúa por completo las
manifestaciones pacíficas desvirtúa por
completo los pedidos que hacen ha sido
muy criticado y se ha tratado de ver
desde la parte legal que esto va en
contra obviamente de la constitución
porque le impide a muchos ciudadanos
movilizarse acceder a sus puestos de
trabajo a sus zonas de estudio porque no
pueden desplazarse esto se ha visto
claramente en la ciudad de cali donde
incluso les cobran dinero para poder
pasar
si yo dio como dos tipos de bloqueos los
primeros son más comunitarios más con
los jóvenes y normalmente dentro de
barrios semi marginales de la ciudad de
cali
y ahí sí hay una experiencia comunitaria
muy disciplinada con quienes realmente
el gobierno debe sentarse a negociar y
parece que muchos de los alcaldes y
gobernadores comparten eso el otro tipo
que sí son los criminales que queman
trajes que buscan que les paguen para
pasar a que nos dejan pasar ambulancias
y que están bloqueando las mismas
carreteras entre ciudades no dentro pero
entre ciudades por ejemplo el doble
puerto de buenaventura
de dónde está la gran parte de las
exportaciones importaciones de colombia
tiene una sola carretera entre ahí y
cada día nuestro país si está carácter
sigue bloqueado lo que no entiendo
diciendo de eeuu y he visto bloqueos en
muchos otros países no puedo pensar en
otro país donde han perdurado tantos
locales por tantas semanas
en carreteras principales del país y
ustedes viene ahora los dos imágenes
todos de los bloqueos son normalmente de
unas pocas docenas de personas no muy
normales y está normal tal vez ni
siquiera armadas en algunos casos hemos
visto como el smart lo hacía rápidamente
varias veces hacia la plaza de bolívar
en el centro de bogotá y otros sitios
pero por alguna razón no actúan en
contra de bloqueos que tienen un choque
sobre sobre gran parte de la economía y
realmente es difícil de entender eso si
es que lo que puede haber uno desde
fuera de las fronteras de colombia es
que el país se puede poner en jaque de
una manera muy fácil con unos bloqueos
en ciudades y en unas cuantas carreteras
y puertos estratégicos y el país empieza
a sufrir desabastecimiento y empieza a
presentar muchísimos problemas es muy
fácil ponerlo en jaque lo que ha
demostrado este bloqueo a lo largo de un
mes senadora guerra ya voy llegando al
final del programa quiero entonces hacer
las conclusiones qué va a suceder
en este mes o lo que venga de aquí en
adelante en este paro en estas
manifestaciones sé que usted es una de
las que no ve con muy buenos ojos la
mesa de negociación no le auguro muy
buen futuro que es lo que entonces usted
ve para más adelante
primero nuestra principal exigencia es
que rápidamente se levanten los bloqueos
como dijo aquí el señor isaacson y sé
que ya ha levantado mucho pero como esta
es una estrategia que llaman hoy
asimétrica porque son grupos que se
mueven rápidamente por todo el lado y
que es lo que estaba buscando era que la
policía o el ejército generara una
chispa para la confrontación entre
colombianos ciudadanos pues por eso creo
que ha habido mucho más cautela de la
policía pero la exigencia nuestra es no
más bloqueo levante el desbloqueo pues
eso lo primero segundo
el gobierno sigue escuchando pero el
gobierno hoy acaba de decirle al comité
del paro que no puede seguir así
mientras no se frene esta violencia
sigue que es muy bus que es muy bueno
exigir pero por el otro lado pedir y no
frenar lo que se está viviendo ir de
cero gobierno el presidente duque va a
continuar en la agenda
e incorporar temas en materia educativo
en materia de ingreso para lo más
vulnerable señor isaksson rápidamente su
conclusión 10 segundos bueno 10 segundos
bueno los bloques en tres ciudades son
un autogol pero el gobierno debe abrir o
son despejados con un mínimo mínimo de
violencia y abrir más el diálogo porque
el diálogo escucha realmente esto más
importante señora jackson rápidamente
gracias la senadora se miró extendiendo
un poco la conclusión gracias a los dos
por haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
debate de france 24 siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]